for more on this story and what it could
mean for President Biden let's bring in
Nancy Cordes she's at the White House
Nancy good morning to you I think a lot
of people keeps you know the Democrats
keep saying there's a big difference
there's a big difference but if you're a
viewer sitting at home I think it may be
hard for you to figure out what the
difference is moving forward how do you
think this is going to affect the Biden
Administration
well it is certainly diverting some
attention Gail from the White House's
agenda at least in the short term and of
course we have no idea how long the
special counsel's investigation is going
to last or where it's going to lead now
White House officials I've spoken to
insist that the public isn't paying all
that much attention to this that
Americans care about other big issues
like the economy and inflation but
Democratic lawmakers I've spoken to do
worry that this is going to make it much
harder to create a contrast with former
president Trump and his mishandling of
classified documents in the run-up to
the 2024 election
the other thing that's so unsettling
Nancy is a drip drip drippity drip that
just keeps coming out about these
documents and the Biden Administration
keeps saying we're very transparent this
is what we did right away do you think
they're upholding their end of the
bargain about being transparent as
they've always promised to be well
they've certainly gotten a lot of
criticism for their decision not to
disclose any of this for two months
until after CBS News broke the story
last week and that may be why the
president's personal lawyer Bob Bauer
came out with a statement over the
weekend trying to explain that decision
he said they were trying to balance the
importance of public transparency with
the need to protect the investigations
Integrity the big question now Gail
going forward is how transparent is the
White House going to be with the
republican-led house oversight committee
which is seeking every shred of evidence
connected to this situation they want
every White House email and they want
those emails within the next two weeks
the White House hasn't said whether it
plans to comply
well it seems both sides have a lot to
talk about Nancy we thank you